[Music]
hello
i'm peyton reed the director of bring it
on thanks for joining us here at the
academy thank you to the academy for uh
hosting
it happens to be the 20th anniversary of
the release
of bring it on uh it was august 25th
2000. hard to believe 20 years have gone
by
and uh we're here to talk about the
movie i'm going to be moderating
and i would like to introduce a few
special guests who are going to join me
today
first off i would like to introduce the
writer of bring it on the creator of the
bring it on world
jessica bendinger hi
hi hey b what's going on oh my god i'm
so excited
excellent uh we have a couple of other
guests
uh i would like to uh deliver a very
warm welcome
to the head cheerleader of the clovers
uh miss gabrielle union hi
hello
hi exactly
thanks for joining us thanks for
watching
we have one final guest uh the captain
of the toro's cheerleading squad
ms kirsten dunst oh kirsten
torrance wow
how's everybody doing how's everybody's
quarantine
[Music]
sound like cheerleaders answering that
question yeah
very strange times we find ourselves in
i cannot believe it's been 20 years
it's incredibly strange and i'm thrilled
that you guys are all
everybody's so busy now um and weirdly
busier now that
there's a pandemic on i'm glad you were
all able to make time for your
for this and your schedules thank you
what i'd like to do is just kind of like
talk about
the journey of the movie and uh i'll
start with you jessica because
it was your script that started it all
and i want you to talk about
a little bit obviously way predating my
involvement in the movie
what gave you the idea to write a movie
about
competitive cheerleading well i was
obsessed with those competitions on espn
and i would watch them i would like
binge them like they were the
kardashians back in the day the
pre-internet 90s i would just watch them
over and over again
and i noticed that they were using a lot
of very kind of
um let's call them homogenized moves
that i recognized from hip hop
and i was like this is so funny this is
appropriation you know this is
um appropriation on a very strange scale
and so i thought well maybe what would
happen if what if what if what if and i
kept asking that question and i ended up
pitching
actually 24 years ago this week i
started pitching bring it on and i
pitched it 28 times i had 27 no's
by the time i got to beacon universal
had already passed in the room i was
like
you guys aren't gonna want this nobody
wants this but here goes and i pitched
my little heart out and here we are
when you were telling me how many times
you had to pitch the movie
it struck me as a really important
lesson to you know
aspiring screenwriters or directors or
anybody about just perseverance because
when you go to a studio or anywhere they
always want a new fresh idea
and yet the thing that scares them the
most is a new fresh idea
yeah that's very well said i don't think
i could have said that better myself
um it was you know it was i knew they
were they would take me to their boss
and then their boss's boss so i knew
there was something to the idea and i
was also getting good notes the whole
time so
the pitch was improving but i was so
inexperienced you know
i was reading off of 13 pages verbatim
like my hand shaking and just
reading my lines um and trying to sell
it but i'm not a performer you know i
get very
i'm very anxious here now doing this i'm
not a performer i get very uncomfortable
and so i was kind of cl white knuckling
my way through it and by the time i got
to the last meeting john shestak who you
know who was a producer on the movie
we'd worked together when i worked in
music videos i
had directed hip-hop videos and had done
some work uh
a couple years earlier so i knew him and
i relaxed and i think that was also part
of it like i was very much myself
and the stakes seemed very low it seemed
unlikely anybody would buy it and
lo and behold here we are and did you
ever experience
personally in the cheerleading world or
what sort of drew you to that world what
kind of research did you do
well i went to camps i went to
competitions i was kind of lurking you
know back in the dial-up days of dirty
dial up
like i would go on these cheerleading
message boards and i'm sure i looked
like a creep like i'd be like hey can
you tell me about
what can i talk to somebody on the phone
and i was stalking these four
cheerleaders on message boards and
somebody finally capitulated and that's
how the wolf swell happened
i was like what is the hardest pyramid
known to cheerleader and they were like
the wolf's wall
um some other research i did was uh
i was dan waters who wrote heather's
warned me don't try to make it teen talk
you'll be time stamped right away and
everybody will know it's super dated
so try and invent language cheerleaders
i mean teenagers like to invent language
so um i talked to some drag queens
in san francisco and i was like what's
going on in drag world what's going on
in drag culture
what if i infuse that into the script
and it
i so that was in there that's in the dna
of the writing of the script after i
pitched it
a lot of drag queens um a lot of gay men
trying jokes on them like the itching
[ __ ] was something i tried on gay
friends and they fell out and i was like
okay that's good
um yeah it was just a process
and then gabrielle i think your
involvement with movie actually predates
my involvement with the movie because i
know jessica you guys did a read through
at some point uh of the script and
gabrielle you were involved in
that how did that come about yeah i got
an
early early early draft and it was
called cheer fever
and i think you guys probably did more
than just the one
uh table read that i did but um the only
other person i remember
being there uh even though it was a big
big group of
uh young actors was ethan embry and he
was reading jesse's role
um but other than that i don't i
honestly don't remember there's probably
like you know
the who's who and the what's what that
were in there and i just don't remember
i remembered like oh ethan embry
um it was very exciting to be at a table
read with ethan embry
he was booking all the things at the
time um
but yeah so i i and i the thing i
remember about that script was
what looked like just a bunch of letters
um kind of strung together and i
couldn't figure out what the word was
and my husband at the time because
there's been more than one husband
since uh and since in our 20 years since
i've got these guys
there's been more than one so the
husband at the time
and i was like what is this what is i
don't know what this is and we were
trying to figure it out and
you know and he goes oh i think they
spelled out what
um martin lawrence says on on the martin
show which is
oh
[Music]
and that was what it was but there was a
line that was like
uh um uh me gonna allow you
my nails are long sharp and ready to
slash
um or yeah meow me gonna ow you
my nails are long sharp and ready to
slash
um you might you know you could mix
those around but those were all in there
um and then at some more
thing with the cheer it was
and it was i was trying in my ridiculous
way to spell that out
or that because i i went with the martin
and
they got a laugh so i was like okay that
must have been it uh
or uh yeah yeah but it it it predated uh
you peyton and then because i don't
think there was a director attached at
that time
and i thought we were doing that table
read for
universal but i you know i've had a lot
to
since the drink 90s i've probably drank
more of my memories than i can recall
but
yeah but then it was it felt like
shortly thereafter
it all kind of came together and i was
offered the role of isis
and kirsten i think even before i came
on that
you maybe had been offered the role but
we're doing another movie
and i know i know this is we're going
way back in time
all i know is when i got the movie i was
in new york
and i was directing uh the upright
citizens brigade show for comedy central
at the time
and i found out i got the movie and
finished my episode and flew back to la
and the first thing i had was i had a
lunch with an actress
who was not you about that role and
uh it was a lovely meeting and then i
left and joseph middleton uh who cast
the movie
said uh well you should know um she's up
for
another movie i was like oh okay and
joseph said um
she's actually up for another
cheerleader movie and my first reaction
was
wait hold on a second there's another
there's another cheerleader movie what's
going on
and anyway that actor passed on our
movie and did the other cheerleader
movie
another oh wait i remember it was like a
violent one right
yeah well sugar and spice sugar and
spice they were bank robbing
cheerleaders
that's right yes yeah anyway
gabrielle you read for that movie or no
did they i want i wanted that i
to this day i mean there's still
something in the back of my mind all
those jobs
my life would have been had i just got
that but yeah they had it was like 172
cheerleader
leads in that movie and they couldn't
they they would not make not a one
black so i i with my tail between my
legs i was like
i guess you know no maybe bring it on
will become
something
other um movie
yeah it's and and tristan i remember
like after that happened then it was
like
who were going to go to it's like i want
kirsten dunst and i think they said well
she passed and i said well
let me talk to her because you know
jessica and i had done more work on the
script and and you were
were you in the czech republic you were
so you know i was in prague doing like
this really crappy movie
um and yeah i remember talking i just
like
my head wasn't or i i watched those
competitions too that jessica was
talking about like me and my
girlfriend's
my best friend molly would watch them
because i was a cheerleader in eighth
grade so like
i definitely was fascinated by those two
um but yeah i kind of like it was a risk
like we were this little movie yeah we
really
gave two shits about right i mean i
really felt like we were just like this
to go to your thing right yeah well it
was interesting because i i'll back up
and say when i first got the
call because i've been looking for a
movie to do i've done a bunch of
television
and my agent called and said hey i know
you you were looking for a movie and i
know you had talked about doing a high
school movie and
i got this script in what's it called
it's called sheer fever i was like
what is that and he said it's a movie
about competitive high school
cheerleading
and my first you know i had not really
been looking for a cheerleader movie
specifically but i said send it and and
i was when i read it i was really struck
in those first two pages
which had that opening cheer and
i was really struck by that and i think
it kind of remained
verbatim in the final movie but the idea
that in like two or three pages
it immediately confronted your
preconceived notions about cheerleaders
yeah musical and it was so in your face
and interesting and it was written with
such
attitude and energy and i got excited
about it was this whole subculture i
knew nothing about and then
as you went further along it started
dealing with some themes that were like
oh
holy [ __ ] this is interesting in a high
school movie this is different
and uh and i got really excited keeps
raising her hand peyton
only because i actually kind of remember
i'm just recalling everything now like i
remember the reason i did the movie is
talking to peyton i was like he's so
cool
and smart and he's gonna do something
really special with this that's what i
did think when i talked to peyton
i had no idea what we were gonna do with
it no i i really i
all i knew is that like i liked
jessica's dialogue
and the characters were so stylized but
it had to be grounded in
reality because when it sort of starts
dealing with
cultural appropriation all those issues
that are you know much more serious
you couldn't take a hard left turn the
movie had to kind of seat it in there
um and like you didn't like the 120 page
version
about the 120 page version of the script
that i was like
so passionate about thank god you talked
me off the ledge multiple times
there was one that dealt with yeah the
hierarchy of the cheerleaders and the
dance squad and all of this stuff it was
it was it was large but you know i
i'd say like looking back at the movie
and what we were trying to do
the movie would have been a failure
without you guys
gabrielle and kirsten jesse eliza all
the other actors
who created real characters and um
my memory of it is like the casting was
such a crucial thing
and casting people who could deal with
the comedy and the drama and of course
the physical demands of the movie but
you guys were so amazing at such a young
age
and willing to kind of help me navigate
that movie because we were touching on
some interesting subjects and some
tricky subjects
um which i like to think is part of why
people might still be talking about the
movie 20 years later um
but i remember wanting it to be real
amidst all the sort of stylized stuff
and i wanted to be fun but also
you know it was good that we didn't shy
away from some of these issues
and and that was always kind of what
struck me in jessica's original draft
that that's what made the movie
different and interesting to me
um and gabrielle i just remember us
having conversations
in the trailer and stuff about all the
you know the character and
and what we wanted to do with isis and
the whole idea and you mentioned to me
at one point i think
gabrielle that in the years since i
don't know if it was a journalist or
someone who talked about
a perception of isis being a villain or
talk talk about that because that's a
very strange read on the movie and a
character but i i want to talk about it
it's a strange read but it's so common
turns out um even just more recently
with those memes it was like
the movies villain and then it was like
the real villain and in
our meme for bring it on it said the the
movies villain and it had
a picture of mike you know me and then
it was like the real
villain and it was a picture of you know
lindsay as big red
and i was like okay so this isn't like
something that a journalist made up this
is like
in pop culture i guess i'm like i guess
isis was the villain and
i thought how wild it is because like
and over
over the years um you know it's it's the
gift that keeps on giving and
i'm i'm asked about it constantly for
the last 20 years
but it is received very differently
from communities of color and from white
folks
and but no one has ever said it to my
face that they thought i was
a villain they said that i thought the
the toro should have won
or you were so you were such a hard ass
but i never thought about
her as being a villain for wanting
equality and accountability
and an equal playing field and to have
to be
recognized for you know her squad's
contributions
it never occurred to me that anyone
could be demonized for that but i don't
know why because that's actually life
but it is very interesting uh how
different
different ethnicities um and and if
whether if you're a part of a
marginalized group how you receive
um the clovers versus the toros and and
uh who you're rooting for and why and
those
it's just very different it's very very
different yeah and i think it's real i
mean obviously it's really
telling about the attitudes in the
country back then
and certainly now and there is i suppose
a depressing aspect of it
that more hasn't changed i mean these
these issues of
you know cultural appropriation and all
those issues were around long before our
movie and continue after our movie
but i do have i have memories of people
talking in sort of coded language to me
over the years about like
well the tours they're really good they
i mean shouldn't they have
won the thing it's like no no no no
that's not what the story is about at
all and that's
it's it's a big tell when people talk to
you about that yeah i mean we stole
all their colors all their dances and
yeah
it's like i mean it's interesting
because kirsten now you you know
with sort of the language of 2020 yeah
you can you can look at torrance very
clearly and she's a poster girl for
white privilege
learns her lesson right yeah and also
like
[ __ ] up along the way you know tries to
make it right and i i always
i um i love the scene how you guys
performed it when
when uh torrance goes to the clovers gym
and they have the the scene about
she's gotten her dad's company to write
a check to get the clovers in
and in her mind and her sort of white
privilege bubble it's like oh okay i'm
doing a great thing
not thinking for a second about how that
is going to be received on the other end
of it
yeah and that strikes me now as you sort
of like
we're talking about white fragility and
you know there are books for white
people about how to
talk about race because americans are so
uncomfortable talking about race
um i like that scene and i think i i
remember us talking about like trying to
get at
the truth of it and also that it really
is about
you know these these rivals and sort of
this desire to have a level playing
field but
it's not easy and it's also like you
know isis doesn't want torrence's
charity at that point they want to get
there on their own merits and prove to
you know prove what they already know
that they're the best
and then in terms of a structure for the
story
you know it had a sort of rocky
structure where in the first rocky
he doesn't beat apollo creed but his
victory in that movie is he goes the
distance
and this one you know for for torrance i
think was the idea that like
they got there on their own merits um
but
you know the clovers were always the
best but it's very it's fascinating to
see how people sort of perceive that
ending and that arc
um back then and even now
do you guys remember shooting that in
that in that uh
gym i do i do too for something i do too
i really do you're right like you rip up
the check
right remember i there was a take where
i rip it up and then
i got stuck on it got stuck on you on my
um and we were like are we supposed to
get it off are we gonna leave it there
is that funny that it's like stuck to
her you should have used that tag peyton
i think it's in the uh i think it's in
the outtakes at the end during mickey
when you guys were doing the cheer for
for mickey i see that scene and i think
about the girls from black i think about
natina obviously and shimari and brandy
and and
how much i miss natina she was just a
force of
nature uh and that and how you were such
a good
mentor gabrielle to them i remember the
first day we were shooting with them
it was the scene outside at night uh the
first confrontation and on those early
takes those girls were looking right in
the lens
and i'm looking at the monitors like is
it just looking in the lens
and i realized that they were used to
just doing music videos where they are
just like singing right into the lens
and
i had to have the conversation with them
you know look at and listen to the
person talking it was fantastic and they
were so
great i remember that night and i and my
my friends had come in town to visit me
and
they were kind of near video village and
i remember dule hill
who had come you know he was charlie on
the west wing and and he's on psych and
a thousand other things and
dooley was like they're looking at the
[ __ ] camera and i was like no no no
no i mean yeah no we're gonna get we're
gonna we're gonna get
and peyton was like okay yeah i didn't i
wasn't i was like i got it i got it
again
so it's like okay guys so but it's like
it was fascinating that they literally
got plucked
from tour within sync they had been on
tour
around the world no breaks no vacation
they were over each other they like
they were they were over each other and
they're and they're young girls right
like there was only like uh brandy's dad
just you know just brandy's dad and so
they were like didn't really have like
parents and they were they were freaking
over it
and so they were looking at this as like
their escape
and i was like yes i want you guys to
have i want you to
ball the freak out i need you to be on
time
yeah i don't care what you do i don't
care if you roll into work but like you
got to be on time
and like so like don't look at the
camera
like just don't just don't look at the
camera like kirsten she's close to the
camera
but look at her don't look at the camera
i mean they were so young i mean you
guys were all so young but they were
young like
kirsten you had just turned 17 when we
started shooting the movie
yeah i felt like the baby too like i
remember because i was
my mom was with me yeah i wasn't 18 yet
so like my mom my brother and i living
in san diego everyone
else was like in hotel rooms partying i
feel like yeah
and some but some nights we would go
like your mom you and your mom would
invite us
and we'd be like okay we got it we gotta
go out because you guys weren't you guys
were like in
like la jolla yeah yeah we had a house
we would drive out to la jolla
and hang out like we'd have like soda
and like
you know chips and like you know very pg
and then we're like plotting like what
bars we were gonna like
you know i was gonna try to get the
girls into who didn't have fake ids
i felt like a camp counselor that entire
summer i mean that's really it was my
first movie i was just
hell-bent on getting the movie done and
making it as great as it could be and i
benefited so much from just the youthful
energy
of all of you on that movie because
everyone was so psyched to be there
and just dug into all the physical
demands of everything and and
i just have this uh feeling about that
movie
which is obviously helped by the fact
that you know when the movie was done
we were coming out with a competitive
cheerleader comedy we were going up
against
i think it was wesley snipes the art of
war which of course
everyone who bets on these things was
like well of course that movie's gonna
be number one but how far down are we
gonna be
and we ended up being number one for a
couple weeks in a row and it was just
um it was insane i don't think that's
oh yeah maybe one smiley i was like that
was that was the craziest thing i
remember going with you payton of
universal studios and like
we would theater hop right and see that
was so fun
i remember you tearing up kirsten
tearing up you're on a cell phone i
guess to one of your reps you're like
i have my first number one movie
so so yeah i i'm curious how uh
in the 20 years since uh how many people
come up and are in your face and want
you to do cheers and all of that stuff
how's it really sort of affected because
you guys have all done so much since
that movie
do people still talk to you about
cheerleading
i mean yeah people will come up and just
quote bring it on to me and everything i
mean
to me it's just such a sense of pride
because we did work hard
it wasn't like a huge budget we were
we we really proved ourselves and like
it was
genuine hard work with such like good
hearts behind it you know
and i think that that it that doesn't
happen all the time it feels so good
when it's like a good group of people
and then we're you know all successful
together
so yeah i get asked i'm like you know
i i can't do cheers on the spot for
people i can't do that
but yeah i won't ask you too i get
quoted you know what i mean
even my best girlfriends some of their
favorite like i'll get the door toward
like
they do it to me like [ __ ] just because
it's a part of
our you know growing up for a lot of
people it's part of our
youth you know and
i and i don't i don't remember the
cheers
and i don't remember like a lot of the a
lot of the dialogue
i've been doing bad things so my brain
cells are like
we have no idea um but like i saw you
recently doing burr it's cold in here
i just i had to learn it for jerry
because i knew he was gonna be doing it
so i didn't want him to be strong out
there like by himself
but like usually i get quoted uh lines
that actually are not
in our movie that they're actually in
not another teen movie and they'll do
the whole
thing and it was actually one of my
girlfriends who you know spoofed me
um her name's tina shavers and so her
version of
me doing it it was like it's already
been brought and i was like that is
not in our movie i never said that and
they were like no no you did you
absolutely did i'm like no
i i did not it's in the spoof
you're like oh yeah i saw that movie
that was great okay i think we have some
fan questions that i've been given here
from
social media and uh i'm gonna start with
let's see
okay um did you take inspiration this is
from nicholas did you take inspiration
from other iconic teen roles
while filming bring it on i didn't but i
don't do that with any movie like i
would
well i do actually like movies that i
like like take inspiration from it but
not
specifically not with bring it on no
yeah
i did gabrielle no i mean it was just
she she's very she's she's a lot like me
i'd like to think
like she's not with the shits she's over
it and it's
it's a new day um not a lot has changed
guys
uh but what i i remember what i did
because i was coming off of
the summer before we did we'd done 10
things i hate about you
and she's all that and i didn't want to
do those
again so um i just remember at the end
of our script
you know uh torrance and isis end up at
cal berkeley cheering together
so i kind of went backwards like and
having graduated from ucla knowing what
it took
at that time to get into the uc system
trying to like
you know infuse isis with you know
the the necessary you know
characteristics that
would have allowed her to to go to you
know berkeley
at that time yes uh yeah i
i again i just think like the two of you
as the captains of those teams i just
there's it's impossible for me to
imagine any other version of this movie
uh with anyone else you guys inhabited
those roles
beyond belief uh all right here's
another one bringing on asks a lot of
tough questions
and does it better than a lot of movies
and in older audiences
um over time have critics and audiences
engaged with
with its themes as much as it deserves
this is from amy
gabriel oh um yeah
no i mean i i think because certainly
with my the
my career trajectory and a lot of the
themes that that a lot of the films i've
been a part of have have covered
this is right in there um in in really
examining race gender
um identity um sexuality
um and and real and a sense of
worthiness like all of those themes are
are kind of um in this and so it's it's
it's withstood the test
of time now there's certain aspects
where people um
you know may judge us more critically or
have
uh you know follow-up questions that
like well maybe you'll address this in
the sequel but i'm like
okay um sure whenever we get to that
sequel that hasn't been done in the 80
sequels that came before us um but i
think
in terms of the larger issues um
we get a lot of a lot of uh kudos for
being ahead of the ahead of the curve
and and dealing with it head-on and not
not in a soft
way and especially the idea of of
torrance
even after she apologizes you know
apologizes for you know
um big red you know stealing from from
the clovers that doesn't absolve her her
her naivete her innocence her apology
does not absolve her
from you know consequences and
people are still they still marvel at
that because
you know in in the last 20 years we've
seen you know
bits of this uh topic covered um
to to varying degrees of of uh no
success
um but you know we we stand that we for
sure stand the test of time
um but they do have questions about like
you know dialogue and
and and the collaborative nature of of
of how we got it done and what really
you know what it really looked like and
what really went into that
and that was i mean that was amazing i
think you know i encourage i think all
the actors to bring themselves
to the roles and and you all did and
gabrielle i think you really
you know you were really ho i know you
were helpful to me and sort of
navigating that and doing in all those
things kind of bringing a reality and
trying to do it and what
felt like a genuine way because we
didn't want to do a movie that was sort
of this frothy comedy
and then when it attempted to deal with
more serious themes just like fell on
its face
and that's that's something i'm i'm i'm
happy with sort of how we
did it um i mean we were and we were
aided
by you know gary hardwick who you know
after
you know he helped us with this you know
i went on and to do a couple other
projects with him
um you know because again it's it's it's
a conversation that we're still having
now
when you have uh interracial
uh writing you know um you know we talk
about this with
with um animated characters and and
who's allowed to write for what and and
to
and and should you be allowed to write
you know
uh interracially and uh you know so it's
it's a conversation that's still com
you know completely relevant and timely
um but the reality is like we we did
need
we did need you know some help and and
gary hardwick was
uh you know kind enough to dive in and
and you know to give us
to give us a leg up and a you know first
person
voice for you know a lot of our a lot of
our
our dialogue as as the clovers
yeah and i think it's tricky and jessica
we can talk about that too because i
mean i remember even at the time
as a white guy making a cheerleader
movie that dealt with issues of race
um it's so fraught and it's kind of a
microcosm for
america and how it's very hard i mean i
don't know if you've
read white fragility or seen the lecture
on it but like the idea of like
white people don't know how to talk
about race combination of just like
guilt or shame or uh all of the above
all the above like very clunkily coming
of age you know
production is a team sport and we're
always doing punch-up on movies and
uh it's such a collective effort and
when the actor feels comfortable
the difference is palpable right and so
that was the case here
and it all worked out it all worked out
and i'm also very proud that certain
things
that i tried my best are were there in
the pitch and they're there in the final
script like a lot of what i wrote is
still there and it's like you build the
house
you do the blueprint and then the
furniture's gonna move around a little
bit
you know and so there are some great
pieces of furniture here and there but
it's um
i'm very proud of the movie i worked for
it six years total
so it's i worked really hard on it i did
my i did my level best and then you have
to go okay what's the process here and
how can we make it even better
yeah i also think that you know if we
were making bring it on now
20 years later it would be from an
entirely different perspective you would
want to be it's just
it's you know in that regard i it's
certainly a product of
its error 20 years ago um and i think
it's interesting to talk about we've
kind of talked around it but the idea
of like if they were going to be further
in this world of streaming or whatever
newer sort of bringing on things the
idea to sort of
we've talked about sort of what that
movie it means one thing to
white kids who saw it when it came out
another thing to black kids when they
saw when they came out
and queer kids and like just all these
different
you know groups and how it really
carries a different meaning and
different weight for all of them
and if you were going to do new stories
you know it would be you'd want to find
new young hungry voices who are not only
tapped into
current pop culture as i no longer am
clearly
but like the idea of like really kind of
hearing you know it's
it's what the industry is trying to do
hopefully
finally is embrace new voices and a
range of new voices because that
is america and that's
that's exciting to me i mean did you
guys all watched cheer
the the docu-series yeah oh my god it
was amazing
i'm obsessed loved it and the queer kids
were
front and center you know that made me
so happy to see
kids you know kids of color and queer
kids just like i felt like a grandparent
you know like oh
you know what we made worked out and
people were inspired and people just did
it
it felt so good to see them succeeding
at such a high level i was like
that was not there when i was going to
competitions that was not there that was
not what it looked like and to see the
difference i was so i'm so
enormously pleased yeah yeah i watched
it and
when someone would come on and and had
three or four concussions
and was still thinking about continuing
with the cheerleading
there was a part of me i looked over at
my wife and i was like am i in some way
responsible for that am i in some way we
thought we were inspiring these kids to
get
multiple concussions and it took me back
to
when we were shooting the thing for all
of those final cheer things
when the cheerleaders do it for real
they you know they practice and they
rehearse and they go on they do the
routine once
but you guys had to do it multiple times
so we could get all the camera angles
and i was terrified
that someone was going to break an ankle
or get a concussion
i can't you guys scared what's that
anyone end up hurting themselves i think
we had one
ankle from one of the cheerleaders who
was i can't remember it was a tauros or
a clover's injury i think it was a
tourism i had a stunt double for some of
it
yeah i was a flyer in high school so i
as you
i don't know i felt like i was pretty
used to certain things but i could i
just couldn't
like do backflips or anything like that
yeah yeah i i
sucked like i you guys had to cut around
me and i always say i'm like don't look
at the wide
shot because i'm not going to match
anybody there's a lot of tight shots
i'm like oh yeah you and then i was just
sort of hidden
like where i was weaker like you're like
just keep dancing gap
just keep dancing let the other kids do
all the stunts you'll be fine off in the
corner
further in the corner further you were
great i remember there are plenty of
wise
really good i was there i was there when
they were shooting that day you were
fantastic you were both my guys
i just remember feeling so old and i was
older than everyone else but i just
remember
smelling of icy hot and like tiger bomb
and everyone's like who is that i'm like
i don't know
just like oh my god and i remember the
scene where i have to get up from that
from the gym to get up and like walk
over to you and you know i rip up the
check
thinking how badly my hips hurt sitting
on the ground
yeah it's all the random things that
come back to me
i was like 27 28.
oh wow okay i think you were 27. i
didn't realize you were
well i didn't realize yeah i felt like i
was like 10 years
older than you and i think you were 17
so i was like 27.
but yeah i just remember like like
everyone's like what was the hardest
part of like getting up off the ground
to rip up a check
um
and also people don't think that when we
were shooting those uh
those nationals routines we were
shooting in oceanside california
for orlando and it was blazing hot it
was
so hot it was that oh my god on the
beach though right
yeah we were on the beach we were on the
beach but we're in those bleachers and
there was no shade
there was only a little bit of shade
depending on the time and we were
chasing
the the the light like oh yeah
change as the sun would like come over
the oh yeah i remember
that right yeah it was a lot remember
and you guys kept saying we can change
the ending at any time
we can change the ending to try to get
us to go full out every time oh as a
threat
who said that did i say that we can
change the ending at any time is that me
i don't remember i mean it was said a
lot because we were like we gotta come
back
no that's uh that was not me
what i must have said i know um
you know i remember there being this
sort of you know it was this challenge
with the toro's final thing and the
clovers
because you had to come up the audience
had to come to that moment not really
knowing who's going to win in terms of
like the competition and stuff
and that the the routines had very
different characters
but also in my head was we have moves in
there that were
illegal on a high school level and only
a collegiate level i couldn't
it was hard to keep all that stuff
straight and i'm sure jessica
cheerleaders
have probably come up to you over the
years and said like well they couldn't
do that thing that violates the
uca how many yeah the more illegal
though the more entertaining it was so
yeah i think the cheerleading i think
the stunt court that your coordinators
all wanted to do like all the stuff they
couldn't do in competition
yeah but i remember in editorial it
became this thing about how
you know we wanted them both to be so
good
and trying to find those things and
people were saying well what was the
point where would they lose points in a
routine and someone it was it was crazy
sort of
from that prism of trying to be true to
cheerleading rules
because it wasn't like doing a
basketball movie or a baseball movie
where i kind of know what the rules are
yeah yeah i needed help in that regard
what else roger ebert called it the
citizen kane of cheerleading movies
i'll take that why not he gave us a bad
review when we opened
i want to say he gave us a thumbs up but
he also
fixated on the um during that period of
time pg-13 movies that were
as he said like cut to within an edge of
like being in our
movie and pushing it in that way which i
think was was the trend at the time
um but yeah he was my neighbor he was
our neighbor in chicago and my dad it
wasn't a great review it was just like
and my dad saw him at the grocery store
carnival grocery and was like um
roger yeah no and so
i love that he revised his opinion he
came out with a more positive opinion
especially
after all as you pointed out his russ
meyer work and all those kind of faster
pussycat movie
kill kill movies he worked on um
he came to compliment us which makes me
very happy the fact that um
people even think about a movie that we
made 20 years ago
is nice i will take that and also if
it's sort of
if it's anybody's like first tiny dip of
the toe
into awareness and sort of
you know looking at the truth of the
world around you i
i when i was reading tallahassee coates
uh
book and he talks about white americans
living in
what he called the dream and it's this
sort of like white picket fence and
everybody you know white kids living in
this sort of bubble
not knowing that everything they have is
built on the backs
of slavery well let's say genocide first
and then slavery the sort of dark
past of america like if it
maybe inspires some kid to actually get
real and talk truthful about
our country that's a whole nother
academy uh zoom webinar we can do
but um who knows i don't know
we uh we touched on a little something
i mean all you can do is open the door
and you have to hope that people will
uh you know gladly walk through the door
because they want to do better once they
know better
um but there's i mean we could like
there's there's
there's so many essays and op-eds that
could be written
off of it off of this movie and have
been
and and the you know the the impact 20
years later and
that it that it had and that it
continues to have and that's
that's awesome and so whatever that we
may
one day come up with i don't know maybe
i mean pearson maybe we're like
i'm kind of the co-head of the pta and
i don't know i don't i don't know what
are we before we run a cheer school
like cheer or like cheer
will we decide who's on the mat yeah the
would-be juries of the world
i don't know i feel like it'd be fun if
we i mean it has to be a competition
against somebody now and jessica again
none of us would be here now if it
weren't your idea to make a movie thank
you for elevating it you guys all
updated it to the highest possible end
and i'm so
you know it's so it makes me so happy
you guys are amazing i can't imagine
anybody else
i can't imagine dreaming up better
people director peyton
isis gabrielle torrance kirsten it's
like a dream come true for a writer so
thank you guys
thanks jessica thank you and what's up
eliza and jesse elizabeth
teddy everybody nathan everybody
rainey all of them yeah yeah
all the crew i know we did that reunion
picture not that long ago it feels like
that but what was that 15 years we did
that
i think it was fine i think that was
like yeah was that five years ago okay
yeah yeah builder back oh my gosh
everybody all the crew so we have to get
everybody together for like zoom
cocktails or something
yeah when people can actually uh be with
people again
in the world it would be great or
virtual cocktails
we'll just drink like we were in san
diego yeah but not you kirsten
yeah but with your mom mom would slide
in a couple
i know i was gonna say i'm sure my mom
would have given you guys a feel
she was she was very kind yeah i would
think not an i not in your eyesight but
your mom was
very cool on the low i'm waiting for
your mom to pop into this
more oh my god
all right well thank you all this was
fantastic all right all right guys
happy anniversary guys happy anniversary
[Music]